good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe I believe in you and
I want to see that awesome thing that
you have inside you explode out into the
universe to have a major impact so to
help you on your journey today's message
is don't get stuck in life over to you
Joe Rogan when you're alone with your
thoughts you get an idea of what your
thoughts actually are if you live your
life just acting constantly on the
momentum of other people's expectations
of you wanting to be liked by these
other people you can run into a trap and
you you you set up a life that you
didn't really want you're you're you're
you're trapped in this situation where
you have a mortgage
you've got credit card bills you've got
student loans you have to pay you have a
bunch going on you have to continue to
feed and all that and especially if you
have a family and you have to feed them
oh my goodness then you're fully locked
in you can't take any chances whatsoever
and oftentimes people make the mistake
of getting stuck and it is just a
tactical mistake just like it would be a
mistake if you got stuck on a video game
just like it would be a mistake if you
followed a map incorrectly and you get
stuck in the woods your life is
certainly some sort of a journey it's
certainly some sort of a journey and we
have to all be aware that when we're
making journeys we're not going to
always make the right steps and
sometimes you have to back up and try
again and if you're in a position where
you can't back up and try again
you've trapped yourself and the system
will set out honey pots for people to
get trapped in the system will set out
the ideas of retirement the ideas of the
golden years providing you benefits
providing you a healthy work environment
why well because they want people to
work for them they don't want people to
realize their own dreams and escape
those yeah so you gotta hire more people
and train them and they want to set it
up so that you stick around
you stick around some sort of an
unsatisfying world it's up to you to see
that video game problem to see that
issue as it comes up on the map known I
think this is a right turn to see all
the problems that could potentially lay
in front of you and calculate your your
future and then also look around all the
people that didn't do it and look at the
misery that they're in and learn it you
don't want to be like them and then look
at the people that are have kind of
taken chances and navigated their way
what did they do differently than you
what would objectivity do they have that
maybe you lack what insight into their
own mistakes are they willing to delve
into that you're not that you step back
and go you know I don't don't I just
don't want to look at myself that
closely but the person who's able to
look at themselves the closest is gonna
get the more rational results one of the
pieces that give advice in my book and
your one word is while you're trying to
figure out the process of finding your
one word spend less time talking to
other people and spend more time talking
to yourself quite often we have an idea
when we wanted to something bold
something big something risky something
groundbreaking co-op on our new path
where we got all excited for this thing
what's the first thing that we typically
do we start going to our friends we go
to our family and we say hey here's this
new thing I want to do I'm really
excited about what do you think
and sometimes the friends in the family
they may give you positive reinforcement
they may tell you some good ideas on how
you might be able to break through with
it a lot of times are gonna be the
little main looking people who hate on
your idea tell you all the reasons why
it's not gonna work out but secretly a
big reason why we're doing it while we
go to other people is the lack of self
confidence you're going because you want
somebody else approval that this is a
good idea like your friend who's never
started a business or become an actor
become a singer or done whatever it is
that you want to go off and do how does
their opinion matter but until you get
their approval or your mom's approval or
whoever it is you want their approval
for something that's what you're
secretly yearning for and it just
represents a lack of self confidence
because if you're constantly trying to
live up to the approval of other people
then you're never building the life
yourself right you're just living on
there other people's expectations and at
what point are you gonna break free and
say it doesn't matter what you think not
in a rude way not in an arrogant way not
now I'm gonna show you way doesn't have
to be from a negative place just doesn't
matter I'm gonna walk through the thing
I want to do even if it doesn't work out
like I'm confident that I just need to
go know when I turn down the high-paying
jobs at university I was one of the only
people who coud
from my class to go to some of these
jobs Merrill Lynch flew me to New York
and put me up in the Waldorf Astoria and
it was me and one other guy from my
class we were the only ones who were
flown out and invited and they wined and
dined us and we're looking at 80 100k
starting salary and flying around the
world and doing these deals I thought I
really wanted to do and all my friends
wanted this job we're all competing for
the same job placements and I ended up
saying I don't want to go that life I
wanted to be a startup entrepreneur and
they all thought it was crazy like what
are you doing this is this is what we've
all been working hard for what do you
hear are you nuts going off and do this
thing and luckily I didn't care enough
about their opinions of me to go off and
do it right so I went off and did my own
business and you know it wasn't that I
was totally confident because as I
struggled in my company and my startup I
was too embarrassed to admit to them
that I was struggling and just told them
I was I was too busy working hard and I
couldn't I didn't have time to come out
to beat the pizza or beer or play pool
or whatever they want to do we're really
I just couldn't afford it I was too
embarrassed ashamed that my lack of
success to admit that to them so it's
not like I was totally impervious and
super self confident but their judgment
of me I didn't care enough about to say
okay I'm gonna hold back my career path
I'm gonna not do the thing that I'm
yearning for that I'm passionate about
that that I want to do that is a scary
thing and I'm gonna do this safe thing
because that's what everybody expected
me and so I'd be really cautious when
you are talking to other people about
your ideas just think about why are you
asking them this idea and do their
opinions matter you know are you asking
because you need validation that this is
a good idea that you're a smart person
that you're a successful person are you
asking because you're generally looking
for ideas to help make this thing happen
are you asking them because you want
them to poke holes in your thing and
you're gonna use that for a positive way
to help you push forward why are you
going and asking for their time for
their opinions for their advice because
most of the time it's not for the right
reasons and I would highly encourage you
to spend more time with yourself
understand your core value I understand
what your one word is and base your most
important life decisions around that
because you have to go off and create a
path on your own at some point like
have to do something that's unique and
different because you are unique and
different right if all you're doing is
living by other people's rules and
ideals and expectations and you're gonna
live your parents life or your friends
life or somebody else's life as opposed
to like breaking free and saying here's
where I'm gonna stand out and it doesn't
mean you have to rub it in people's
faces or tell people that they're wrong
or say here's why you guys suck work in
a sub job and I'm gonna go up and do my
amazing thing you don't have to do it a
negative way but there's a way for you
to stand up and be yourself and chase
your thing without having to bring
people down and one moment that I really
remember strong in my life was five six
seven years after we graduated one of my
friends that I went to university Worth
came to me and said hey I'd love to love
your advice and we sat down in the
coffee shop and he was explaining to me
how much he hated his job and how all of
our university friends were hating their
jobs and we're looking for ways to start
their own business and wanted my advice
and how to do it and I would just
remember thinking man I'm so glad I
didn't take that path like that was
almost me I almost went and took that
job and did that thing that now would be
in his position hating my life trying to
figure out how to be an entrepreneur and
I'm so glad I did that you know five six
seven years earlier so I encourage you
to do the same thing spend more time
with yourself spend less time caring
what other people think of you and stop
getting stuck in life so the question
day today is I'm curious when was a
moment when you had to say no to
somebody seeing over their expectations
and go off and do your own thing whether
it worked out or not you had to say I'm
gonna go off on my own path and I need
to just know if it's gonna work or not I
have to at least try when was that
moment for you I like to bring some
excitement and encouragement from you
that hopefully will also inspire the
people watching and read in the comments
that they can go off and do the same
thing so please share your thoughts in
the comments below I also want to give a
quick shout to Adrian Caudill Adrian
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word it really
really means a lot to me and I hope you
enjoying the read thank you guys again
for watching I hope you have an amazing
day I believe in you I hope we continue
to believe in yourself
and whatever your one where it is much
love and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of vinspresso
Spray so give me go
you have to actually show up every day
and inch yourself forward toward these
streams and not only show up every day
and once in a while into yourself I mean
every day you have to actually take an
action that moves you forward not just
research not just thinking look the
power of an intention is great but
without any initiative it's dead right a
dream is great but without any movement
it's dead you have to be moving towards
every day you can send an email every
day you can make a call every day you
can write something every day you can
create something every day you can
contribute something every day but it
has to be daily otherwise it will never
become actualized and the highest
performers in the world didn't get there
because they were lucky they worked at
it longer than everyone else they had a
better work ethic and it's not that they
necessarily always worked harder they
work smarter because they were doing the
research they were taking the time to
visualize how they would be distinct
different how they would survive the
tough times they really kept at it keep
every single day momentum going and if
you don't do that there's no chance make
your I can more important than even your
IQ now you're saying Robin what are you
talking about right here well a lot of
people get stuck in victimhood versus
leadership by the seduction of saying
well I'm not smart enough I'm not
intelligent enough well you are
intelligent enough what's even more
important is your mindset of possibility
you see if you look at the best athletes
in the world the best musicians in the
world the best entrepreneurs in the
world the best managers in the world the
best CEOs in the world the best coders
in the world the best pizza makers in
the world the best moms and pops etc etc
those who get elite level results are
not the most intelligent or naturally
gifted people in their field but these
are the people that have that mindset of
possibility and it's all about I can and
that might sound like a bit a bit of a
platitude you know having an attitude if
I can
mindset of possibility a mentality of
legendary but when you really
deconstruct it it's really true if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you up or
so it would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details